la mobilisation des gilet jaune qui
continue c'est la 13e journée
consécutive
ils sont de plus en plus soutenu d'après
les derniers sondages on vous explique
tout ça en vidéo puis on s'en parle
juste après les gilet jaune continue
chaque jour à faire parler d'eux et
malgré la mauvaise publicité que
certains dérapages entretiennent autour
du mouvement les français semblent
toujours plus solidaire avec les
participants à cette révolte
selon un sondage réalisé par est là pour
bfmtv 75% des sondés soutiennent
l'initiative des gilet jaune
un pourcentage qui atteint même les 83 %
chez les classes populaires
alors que beaucoup se plaignent des
blocages qui ont lieu dans toute la
france depuis le 17 novembre dernier
ce sondage semble montrer que 69 % des
interrogés sont favorables à la
poursuite de ses actions pour faire
réagir le gouvernement et les stars se
mettent aussi à suivre le mouvement
patrick sébastien arnaud ducret encore
le comédien franck dubosc eux se sont
montrés solidaires avec les manifestants
moi je vous soutiens les gilet jaune
c'est voilà je suis avec vous que ce
soit les dom tom la métropole en les
touchant sombre la même galère on en a
marre de casquer comme des porcs le mec
est avec son gilet jaune il a juste la
vision de la fin de mois de son gosse à
l'école et voilà on va trouver quelque
chose on va tous ensemble faire quelque
chose et les rangs des stars qui
soutiennent les gilet jaune grandissent
de jour en jour bref un mouvement qui
semble très populaire auprès des
français
mais selon vous pourquoi sont ils plus
de 70% à soutenir les gilet jaune
alors pourquoi 70% des français sont-ils
derrière les jets les jeunes et puis
alors chaque jour on voit de nouvelles
catégories on avait dit tout d'un coup
que effectivement il y avait une
catégorie de la population un peu hors
sol qui au coup qui était très
silencieux et qu'on n'entendait pas
notamment les vedettes les stars et puis
là on les voit apparaître sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'est ce que vous en
pensez raymond par exemple 70% ça me
paraît logique parce qu'on est tous un
peu gilet jaune à part le mec qui
travaille en bas de chez lui qui va au
boulot en trottinette électrique et qui
est aisé qui a pas de souci dans la vie
il se pète un peu moins gilet jaune et
10 faut laisser les gens travailler mais
on est tous un peu j'ai jaune moi je
bosse par exemple à 45 bornes demande
j'habite à 45 bande de mon travail je
suis j'ai déjà oublié sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens qui vous êtes étoiles
de tu gagnes 600 euros par émission sept
cent pas dans le temps des chiffres tepa
gilet jaune parce que tu es atppc marie
créteil pmp ça va s'arrêter après je
vais retourner à mes livraisons
donc je suis gilet jaune je suis avec
eux est d'ailleurs samedi j'ai peur pour
sa vie mais je vais quand même y aller
et je comprends très bien que les gens
soient 70%
parce que c'est tout le monde n'y a pas
de légers les jo ne s'est pas un
mouvement c'est tout le monde sait déjà
c'est des gens qu'on gère la société de
leur vie
ces retraités qui se comptent congo ses
41 ans du jour au lendemain se retrouve
sur les champs avec la police ils
comprennent pas bien à guînes clément a
mille fois raison au départ
effectivement ce mouvement c'est la
colère l'exaspération le ras-le-bol des
classes populaires et des classes
moyennes et sauf que après il ya les
gouvernements et les politiques qui sont
sourds et aveugles et qui les dénigrent
en permanence et je pense
qu'effectivement tout le monde dans
toutes les grandes démocraties
aujourd'hui en europe aux états-unis les
classes populaires aujourd'hui n'en
peuvent plus et écrit stop et on se rend
compte que y compris ceux qui n'ont pas
de soucis se disent proches de gilet
jaune et comprennent et hélas pas
typiquement on a demandé à des masses
des mois sébastien va plus loin il dit
au delà de idy l'eau au delà de
l'oseille pardon il dit moi on m'a
toujours présenté comme le gros
blaireaux le gros beauf est d'ailleurs
le gouvernement est un peu comme ça il a
un peu dénigrer traverser la route vous
allez trouver du boulot tu veux un
costard met à 4 lâcheté ou takabosser en
version d'enseignement donc a eu plein
plein de choses comme ça qui ont été
pour moi des erreurs des erreurs
magistrales et justement une étude pour
bfm qui a dévoilé que 75% des sondés
soutiennent ou éprouvent de la sympathie
pour les gilet jaune c'est quand même un
gain de 5 points en une semaine on
aurait pu croire que il comme il y avait
quelques dissensions ou bien y avait eu
des échauffourées ça aurait baissé pour
sont au contraire ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment profond regarde et vois la
vidéo voilà 75% de sympathie et de
soutien 17% d'opposition hostilités et
8% dans différents jeux pas comment on
peut être indifférent c'était à 7 sur
l'histoire oui moi je comprends tout à
fait le mouvement est mise en raison je
suis je suis
moi j'y suis allé samedi dernier j'ai
écouté les gens jeu
rivoire et je dois dire que j'ai entendu
des trucs hallucinants des trucs bon
c'est vrai qu'on vit différemment
moi j'ai écouté des gens qui m'ont
bouleversé il y avait une dame notamment
qui arrivait de je ne sais plus quel
endroit qui gagne 450 euros qui élevé
seul son gosse handicapées n avait
aucune subvention pour le gosse
handicapées ce qui est curieux
normalement il y en a une de 800 euros
elle n'a pas eu je sais pas comment
c'est passé il ya une détresse profonde
et je comprends désespérément stérile
temps sur les plateaux de télé la folk
on n'entendait pas c'est peut-être ça
aussi long des gens qui ont eu
l'impression d'être méprisés de ne pas
être entendus dans des patrick sébastien
dit que lui et méprisés par ce que il
aime ces gens là ils ces gens là ce sont
mes préfacé gens là on en fait tous
partie ce qui a fait leur force c'est
qu'il y avait peu y a pas d'état lorette
ya pas de la représentation des gels et
je ne savais qu'il y avait huit
représentants et ils sont normalement
reçu par edouard philippe vendredi qu il
les recevra des je crois quand on dit à
14 heures voilà sauf que maintenant même
il y en a qui ne veulent plus y aller
notamment il ya eric drew et qui est
l'un des membres de la délégation qui
est initiateur du mouvement de
contestation qui a annoncé qu'il ne se
rendrait pas chez le premier ministre je
crois qu'on a un petit une petite un
petit magnéto nos ou un petit je me
retiens bike wifi g pour un car de la
délégation je refuse de me rendre demain
chez le premier ministre aucune
délégation n'a encore le rôle de
représenter les gilet jaune est ce que
ça va pas être un problème ça et si
justement c'est ça le problème je leur
ai dit savoir les a reçus encore hier
soir je leur ai dit il y avait deux
porte parole ils n'aiment pas qu'on les
appelle comme ça mais il y avait deux
personnes qui les représentait hier soir
danser dans cette émission il faut
vraiment qu'ils arrivent à se coordonner
alors heureusement c'est la politique
heureusement il n'y a pas de peu le
parti a pas de celle ci c'est à dire est
que le regard mais moi je leur ai dit
deux choses je leur ai dit hier soir il
faudrait que vous arriviez à vous
décider
lenari les porte parole après les
rejeter c'est très compliqué pour
communiquer et en plus surtout que même
essaie de créer ma propre service de
sécurité pour éviter les casseurs très
vite on est
on est dans les vrais problèmes humains
et non pas envie que ce soit gérer
politiquement c'est à dire qu'on essaie
la france d'en haut il ya plus beaucoup
de france d'en haut aujourd'hui et la
france d'en bas c'est à dire des gens
qui ont perdu énormément et d'ailleurs
on a tous perdu en pouvoir d'achat et de
l'autre côté vous avez des politiques
nous explique que si vous passez la
voiture électrique à 17000 euros avec
une prime à 6 min ça veut dire 11000
euros et qu'en plus on vous offre un
microcrédit derrière vous allez pouvoir
vous en dire sur ce que quand vous avez
800 euros par mois c'est vous devez
faire écrit à 250 euros par mois il faut
juste un local expression revient pas
c'est du mépris exactement l'autre
information c'est bien évidemment que ce
samedi by à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation qui est prévu ce qui
inquiète certaines personnes alors ça a
été très commentée parce qu'il ya
beaucoup qui sont demandés s'il fallait
pas carrément fermer les champs-elysées
ou au contraire carrément les ouvrir et
dire allez-y
le lieu est autorisé à ce sujet ce matin
dans l'émission morandini leicher ses
news noah manoir policiers délégué
syndical vigie police pense même qu'il
faudrait interdire carrément l'axé
regarder il va falloir être extrêmement
prudent samedi on allait gilet jaune qui
veulent à tout prix aller sur les
champs-elysées parce que c'est
symbolique parce qu'ils veulent
descendre vers matignon et vers le
palais de l'elysée après je pense que
c'est important de au plan symbolique de
protéger les lieux de pouvoir
mais je pense que les commerçants et les
riverains ont aussi des attentes
en ce qui concerne leur propre sécurité
donc vous dites à venir sur les champs
serait d'interdire les champs elysées à
la manif samedi ce serait au niveau
sécurité en parle de sécurité balance ce
serait du bon sens alors quand même pour
les gilet jaune c'est un lieu symbolique
ça leur permet d'avoir une visibilité
maximale parce que les champs elysées
c'est connu dans le monde entier
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que les
gilets jaunes c'est un mouvement
pacifiste il ya des gens qui sont
infiltrés il ya des casseurs le problème
il est là donc il faut pas tout mélanger
son palais gilet jaune dont il faut
avoir peur donc à un moment donné il
faut être qui que les gens entendent il
faut qu'ils aient un moratoire et que
ces gens soient entendus que la france
d'en haut d'en bas soit entendu oui mais
je trouve qu'il ya une nouvelle
politique un nouvel un nouveau mouvement
apolitique
depuis le maquereau nouvelle nouveau
style politique mais que des gars
gisement n'avait guère l'ajax ou des
nouveaux styles de manifestations et je
pense que là on doit innover en matière
d'ordre public
maintenant justement on ne sait pas
comment faire sur les champs-elysées
interdire ne pas interdire autorisé
comment faire
la l'ordre public doit innover lizonne
chance extraordinaire d'innover en
laissons les gens peut-être circuler
parce qu'on voit qu'ils ne vont pas
obéir mais il faut qu'ils innovent en
n'ayant pas beaucoup de moyens pas
beaucoup d'hommes mais doivent innover
on voit rouler innovait en tout cas une
solution
il ya également les gilet jaune on va
pas se mentir c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne très très bien dans les
médias parce que comme c'est quelque
chose qui nous concerne tous et que les
10 les téléspectateurs sont très
intéressés il ya beaucoup d'appétence
sur cette information là parce que
d'abord il ya une information de
proximité est ce qu'on va être bloqués
en bas de chez soi ou est ce que il y
aura des gilets jaunes d'oeufs ou si on
a envie d'aller manifester où quand
comment et c'est donc il ya des débats
qui ont lu un petit peu partout ça avait
été initiée quand même et fall romain le
remarquer dans btp avec cyril hanouna
qu'on peut saluer dire bravo parce que
vraiment à faire défaut
et autre débat qui a eu lieu c'était
hier soir sur lci un débat entre gilet
jaune et membres du gouvernement et la
société civile ça fait un carton
d'audience soit que 920 téléspectateurs
un pic à 1 million ce que n'a jamais
fait lci à cette heure ci je crois qu'on
a un petit vidéo d'ailleurs parce qu'il
ya eu un clash lors de cette soirée un
clash entre romain goupil me connaissait
un réalisateur français qui est une
figure de mai 68
eric drew est justement dont je vous
parlais qui est un des porte-parole des
gilets jaunes qui justement un de ceux
qui ne veut pas se rendre voir le
premier ministre vendredi regarder il
s'est passé sur les sur la façon dont
font aussi les arrêter c'est bagnoles 2
de deux élus qu'ils allaient faire des
courses et aller faire des courses et
tout d'un coup yade inde et gilet jaune
qui dit c'est un pdf et koné voilà
qu'est ce qui s'est passé jugé médiocre
et ceux ci s'étaient pas compter et 5100
du mouvement alors pas trop grave mais
qui je m'adresse et de mouvement
en fait sur 5 % des blocages qui va mal
se passer vous allez définir le blocage
en lui-même en entier c'est ça donc sur
la population des valeurs 5% de voleurs
toute la population d'être des voleurs
c'est ça que vous définissez ça comme ça
vous essayez le montant comme ça alors
ça c'est symptomatique de cette tension
aussi il ya une tension c'est vrai les
gens du mal à se parler c'est parfois ça
devient difficile
ça devient difficile on l'a vu
effectivement sur le plateau ici avec
l'innovation de cyril hanouna
j'aime bien david pujadas mais il faut
quand même remarquer car l'intérieur du
journal de 20 heures de tf1 ils ont fait
3 ou 4 renvoi ou et vers la gare elle
sait y est c'est fait ça aussi je pense
que même la vérité sur harry a perdu 1
million le million et s'y retrouver ou
fait devant elle si non mais c'est
incroyable bien sûr et aussi
intransigeant avec un report à roland
évident bien sûr alors on a posé la
question à nos téléspectateurs est ce
que vous soutenez le mouvement des gilet
jaune et ce qu'il sait ils sont en train
de huy à 71% non à 29 à 100 à ses
records négatifs à la mort de ce qui se
passe ici ou et delphine pour conclure
oui en fait ça augmente de plus en plus
au tout début du mouvement les gilets
jaunes c'était un peu si on faisait un
itinéraire par exemple moi je regardais
avec le gps comment éviter les gilets
jaunes j'étais une heure les bouchons et
au machin aujourd'hui on a compris ce
qu'ils veulent
heureusement qu'ils aient des tribunes
publiques comme ça et médiatique on
comprend et puis je voulais aussi dire
l'histoire qui met en place avec le
gasoil à prix coûtant il ya deux jours
je suis allé faire donc le plein comme
tout le monde à prix coûtant c'est
génial au moins ils nous donnent un peu
quelque chose il y avait marqué débit
réduit c'est à dire que les gens s'ils
voulaient faire le plein à prix coûtant
c'était dix minutes donc moi j'ai passé
dix minutes c'était centime par centime
d'aidé ponte maintenant qui bloque à 30
euros c'est dingue
il faut vraiment is a man mais bon c'est
aussi un mode d'action pour essayer de
se faire entendre et c'est le moyen
qu'ils ont de notre vie de fait le truc
nouveau en fanfare nouveau c'est un truc
qui est qui et qui me choque moi c'est
que là j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernant a pas compris que là c'est
pas être c'est pas la sncf c'est pas les
fonctionnaires c'est pas les
ambulanciers s'élancer la france et
c'est pour ça que moi je veux pas qu'ils
aient de délégations en fait on reste
comme ça et on continue ainsi il ne fait
pas de délégation non mais quand ils
vont entendre à un moment donné on est
obligé d'en prendre des mesures
évidentes et les motiver à réagir ce
pardon et donc que le premier que le
premier ministre il a reçu aujourd'hui
un gilet jaune qui faisaient la grève de
la faim oui c'est vu sa tête chez à la
grève de la quel prix mais quand même à
quel prix a effectivement a quand même
pris déjà que c'est très compliqué pour
eux on est on est de tout coeur avec eux
on pense évidemment à toutes ces
personnes qui
[Applaudissements]